it is a natural assumption that in
philosophy before we start to deal with
its proper subject manner that is the
actual cognition of what truly is one
must first of all come to an
understanding about cognition which is
regarded either as the instrument to get
hold of the absolute or as the medium
through it one discovers it a certain
uneasiness seems justified partly
because there are different types of
cognition and one of them might be more
appropriate than another for the
attainment of this goal so that we could
make a bad choice of means and partly
because cognition is a Faculty of a
definite kind in scope and thus without
a more precise definition of its nature
and limits we might grasp clouds of
error instead of the heaven of truth
this feeling of uneasiness is surely
bound to be transformed into the
conviction that the whole project of
securing for consciousness through
cognition what exists in itself is
absurd and that there is a boundary
between cognition and the absolute that
completely separates them for if
cognition is the instrument for getting
hold of absolute being it is obvious
that the use of an instrument on a thing
certainly does not let it be what it is
for itself but rather sets out to
reshape and alter it if on the other
hand cognition is not an instrument to
that our activity but a more or less
passive medium through which the light
of truth reaches us then again we do not
receive the truth as it is in itself but
only as it exists through and in this
medium either way we employ a means
which immediately brings about the
opposite of its own end or rather what
is really absurd is that we should make
use of the means at all it would seem to
be sure that this evil could be remedied
through an acquaintance with the way in
which the instrument works for this
would enable us to eliminate from the
representation of the absolute which we
gain through it
whatever is due to the instrument and
thus get the truth in its purity but
this improvement would in fact only
bring us back to where we were before if
we remove from a reshaped thing what the
instrument has done to it
than the thing here the absolute becomes
for us exactly what it was before this
accordingly superfluous effort on the
other hand if the absolute is supposed
merely to be brought near to us through
this instrument without anything in it
being altered like a bird caught by a
lime twig he would surely laugh our
little ruse to scorn if it were not with
us in and for itself all along and of
its own volition for a ruse is just what
cognition would be in such a case since
it would with its manifold exertions be
giving itself the air of doing something
quite different from creating a merely
immediate and therefore effortless
relationship or if my testing cognition
which we conceive of as a medium we get
to know the law of its refraction it is
again useless to subtract us from the
end result for it is not the refraction
of the Ray but the Ray itself whereby
truth reaches us that is cognition and
if this were removed all that would be
indicated would be a pure direction or a
blank space
Hegel begins the introduction to the
phenomenology by situating us within the
realm of what we can call
epistemological concerns and this is
very much in tune with the the sort of
grand sweep of modern philosophy which
was in many respects dominated at least
in its theoretical approach and the
theoretical approach really did dictate
the practical approach in many cases by
a focus on what it is that we can
possibly know and what we're
contributing to knowledge and you know
what conceals the truth from us what
reveals the truth to us so there's that
aspect Hegel is going to talk about it
in terms of cognition or katniss and you
notice of getting your epistemological
preliminaries to philosophy in modern
philosophy for many of the people
involved in it epistemology really does
become first philosophy as opposed to
metaphysics being first philosophy now
on the other hand you can't get away
from metaphysics you can't get away from
some sort of connection to being as such
or if you want to put it in terms of you
know other things as well its meaning to
some sort of overarching good Hegel will
actually talk in terms of the excellent
at many points as we've seen in the
preface and so we've got this absolute
over here and that constitutes sort of
another pole to modern philosophy on the
one hand you know if you look at figures
like Descartes or lock or Hume or can't
what you're seeing is this intense
emphasis on trying to figure out what it
is that we can actually take as starting
points what what we can rely upon if
anything what it is that we the knower
are doing through our knowing through
our acts of knowledge through our our
organizing things through imposing
categories as concepts through
associating things as Hume is going to
say but I you know on the other hand
and at another pole there's also this
sense that look there's something bigger
there's something that we want to get to
we don't want to just be doing this sort
of you know essentially navel gazing
activity of enumerate the different ways
in which we can get to know things and
you know the different ways in which we
can fail to know things we want to
actually know something we want to know
something not just about individual
things and we don't just want to do
science in the sense of you know
laboratory experiments or engaging in
Natural History we want to have a sense
of the totality we want to make we want
to make sense out of the all and so
Hegel has got these two different
moments here our cognition and the
absolute and the question is what's the
relationship between them so he says
it's a natural assumption that in
philosophy what's going on in philosophy
before we get to start to deal with its
proper subject matter the actual
cognition of what truly is that that
would be metaphysics and to a certain
degree that would also involve say
philosophy of action moral philosophy
philosophy human nature we have to
engage in something else one must first
of all come to an understanding about
cognition and he's going to raise this
this dichotomy here this you know what
could it be this or could it be that two
different possibilities do we look at
cognition as something like an
instrument an apparatus that we bring to
our in a world out there that we're
experiencing or perhaps turn inward when
we're engaging in reflection and thereby
make sense out of things is cognition
like an instrument is there an active
sense a productive sense to what's going
on in knowledge what's going on even an
imagination or is it more like a medium
and what he says medium he means
something like a telescope or a
microscope or just looking through glass
as such or looking through water or you
know you could think about what we're
doing right now is a medium it's kind of
a weird one because it does involve an
apparatus which is doing weird things
too
now it's breaking down the light into
its constituent parts and I have no idea
how a digital camera actually works
quite honestly if you pressed me upon it
but you know we tend to think of it as
sort of the legged medium I suppose an
analogue hyrum camera would be much more
medium and less apparatus a digital
cameras more apparatus and in some sense
less media but these are the
possibilities and he says there was a
certain uneasiness a certain worry why
because there's different kinds of
cognition there's different modes of
getting to know things and I think we're
more or less familiar with this getting
to know a person is a different kind of
knowing than knowing you know how to
sing a song or knowing that two plus two
equals four those are different types of
cognition there and we don't have to
worry about trying to numerate them
right now that's not the point that
Hegel is trying to make he just wants to
say look there's different kinds of
cognition and so perhaps one type of
cognition might be more appropriate than
another for cognizing the absolute and
you know that would make sense are you
going to be able to understand the
absolute through the processes of
natural science probably not are you
gonna be able to do through mathematics
we've already seen Hegel tackle that
sort of thing back and the preface are
you going to be able to do it through
intuition Hegel says no because
intuition is really just sort of random
whatever it is that we happen to feel at
the time and we you know you can't
rationalize it or we endow it with some
some dignity by thinking that it's it's
revealing something to us no others
there's going to be a different kind of
cognition involved and the question is
what what is that going to be so he says
we could make a bad choice of means we
could pick the wrong way to go about
figuring out what actually is the case
not just what's the case right here or
right now what's the case in in toto
in the totality of things
including us so it matters whether we
pick an instrument or a medium and this
was really you know an epistemological
point you could say that modern
philosophy is dominated by this worry by
this concern about wait a second people
have been saying that this is the way we
get to know reality this is the way we
get to know the world is the way we get
to know ourselves this is the way we get
to know God if there is such a thing
maybe you know we're picking the wrong
one we have to be very careful and we
need to look at this end of things and
figure out which ones are the
appropriate was and if you look at some
of the thinkers who I've been mentioning
like John Locke for example or Immanuel
Kant or Rene Descartes they are really
focused also Benedict Spinoza really
focused on figuring out what modes of
cognition we ought to be using for what
kinds of purposes
so Hegel's goes Army says cognition is
is a Faculty of a definite kind scope so
if we don't have a precise definition of
its nature and limits we might grasp
clouds of error rather than the heaven
of truth and again that is the nightmare
of epistemological you know speculation
in the modern period maybe we're really
insane maybe we're really being deceived
by an evil you know evil genius evil
demon that's coming from Descartes right
they hurt didn't really think that by
the way but that's what a lot of people
have taken from Descartes maybe we can't
rely on cause reality at all maybe maybe
that's just our brains or our minds just
associating things that aren't really
totally dependable that's Humes point
and then you know Kant resolves that by
saying oh don't worry about causality
were it's not really out there in the
world we're imposing that on experience
so that it can be experienced for us
through the categories of the
understanding but you see this this
theme over and over again over again we
got a look at this stuff here before we
worry about you know getting to the
absolute we have to really get this
issue settled or else we're
to pick the wrong thing and we're gonna
be like the rest of those dummies
through the history of philosophy who
didn't have the right idea about this
that's another typical modern conception
that we can break with the past like
that so he says this feeling of
uneasiness is surely bound to be
transformed in the conviction that the
whole project of securing for
consciousness that's us through
cognition what exists in itself is
absurd and there's a boundary between
cognition and the absolute that
completely separates them
this is skepticism this is skepticism of
a sort which says we can never really
get to this thing over here that's most
real because there's always something in
the way and that something is the way in
which we get to know the absolute now
you can say well how do you know about
that knowledge and about the absolute
and that's that's where Hegel is going
with us so he says if cognition is an
instrument for getting a hold of an
absolute being we've got a problem don't
we what happens when we use an
instrument does an instrument leave
alone what it is that it's working upon
it really depends on what kind of
instrument doesn't it think about what
goes on with this camera are you getting
the whole picture of what's going on
here not exactly
you know there's editing software
usually the light is not good enough you
know the way the cameras taking it so I
boost it up a little bit the sound is
usually not quite as strong as I'd like
it to be so I boost that up a bit as
well there there's capacities for
modifying what it is that you're you're
supposed to be taking it yeah you know
when if you think about a camera again
you know when you turn the camera
towards something you're selecting out a
portion of what it is that's in your
visual field it's kind of interesting to
you I think about I go to heavy metal
concerts because I love heavy metal some
of you may know that already and one of
the things that I do
and I'm kind of you know typical guy
this way a typical guy of the 21st
century as I get my iPhone and I'll like
I want to do this a few times in the
concert but when I when I have an
inkling that it's gonna be a really
great song then I got the iPhone up but
I'm recording it now I'm looking through
that viewfinder thing and later on I can
watch that so you know maybe it's Judas
Priest and they're playing living after
midnight or you know the rage or
something like that
and I am not taking in the same thing
that the the spectacle on stage actually
is is sort of presenting to me I'm
looking at a little screen aren't I
as opposed to you know sir just taking
it in and there's something about the
act of interposing the camera there that
changes the experience as well now I
gotta like concentrate on trying to hold
it steady and funny enough you know
because we never get you know super
great seats like front row cuz those are
very expensive you can see what I'm what
I'm taking my film there might my image
of it that there will be some other
people in front of me and you can see
their screens lit up filming the same
thing so you know that's a sort of prime
example we could think of many other
examples the point is that an instrument
modifies the thing that it is working
upon
so Hagel will say if cognition is the
instrument for getting hold of absolute
being if are active you know not knowing
or or investigating is how we get to
know absolute being if it's active like
that then the use of an instruments on a
thing certainly does not let it be what
it is for itself so we're not getting
what it is in itself instead we're
getting what it is for cognition or what
it is for us or what it is for this
particular instrument of cognition so
you says it reshapes it and alters it
we're not getting what it is that we
wanted to in the first place this is the
dialectic at work by the way you know
you think that you're doing acts and it
turns out that you're not just doing
you're also doing why and why kind of
screws up what's going on with X so that
X doesn't turn out to be what you were
doing at all just what you intended to
do now he says dance oh that that's a
problem
what if cognition is just a medium what
if it's something like you know seeing
through a window or hearing you know we
hear through the air the sound waves in
pinja pasa the air is the medium sound
waves are what are carried into Tori
here's the you notice I have drawn sort
of arrows here that that seems to be you
know like the absolute is coming to us
then and the medium is not really doing
anything since it's a more or less
passive medium through which the light
of truth reaches us but the problem is
we don't get the light of truth as it is
in itself what we get is what that
medium allows to pass through so think
of it as sort of a filtering system you
know if you change the air you change
the sound as a matter of fact this is a
great example sound because you know one
of the reasons why I have to tweak the
sound as I process these videos is
because the acoustics in this place
where I'm shooting are not particularly
good and there's some background noise
so there's some some other things going
on here and other places where I should
it might sound very echoey that's
because the medium is not quite the same
so if we're doing that with knowledge if
knowledge is a medium through which the
light of truth just sort of comes
through if we're not making an active
contribution to it we're still getting
it through some sort of filtering
through some sort of selection process
one that we're not really conscious of
so you know take for example light we
look at flowers flowers are very
beautiful I love flowers I'm very
interested in them and growing them and
sniffing them and you know
looking at them I even wanted to be a
florist at one time believe it or not we
don't see flowers the way that these do
dewy bees can see into the ultraviolet
and turns out that when you put flowers
under ultraviolet lights and you look at
them with an ultraviolet camera you can
see that it doesn't look quite the same
same with butterflies also you know the
smell I'm sure that it the flowers smell
very different to to bees than they do
to us
same with with peace so the medium can
also end up being a kind of contributor
and yeah we're dealing with how it is
for us and we're not dealing with the
absolute as it is in itself in that case
so he says either way we employ a means
which immediately brings about the
opposite of its own end that means that
we're trying to do something but we're
somewhat self-defeating in what we're
trying to do because we're picking a
tool or a means we're picking something
that is going to prevent us from
actually being able to do what it is
that we intend to do so again this is
the the dialectic at work the fact that
we can we can register this the fact
that we can we can understand this the
fact that we can make sense of this
that's the dialectic so it says it seems
rather absurd we should make use of a
means at all so he says how could we get
around this this evil could be remedy
this this badness could be dealt with
through an acquaintance in which with
the way in which the instrument works so
that's what epistemology does it looks
at the mind or it looks at the act of
knowledge or it looks at the human being
and says how does this actually house
knowing this investigating this is
coming to understand how does that work
let's focus on that before we worry
about what it is that we're doing let's
figure out how does knowledge actually
work how does thinking actually work
and that's you know that's this grand
movement of epistemology so we can focus
on the instrument or we can focus on the
medium and with both the instrument and
the medium one tack that we can take is
we can say let's try to figure out what
in fact this is adding in and then we'll
just subtract that so once we know that
it's doing this to the object that we're
working upon we'll just take that part
away and then we've got the object as it
is in itself for us or you know what the
medium if we know that the medium is
turning everything yellow let's take
that yellowness out and then we'll have
the the absolute restored to us now is
that going to work
he says if we remove from a reshaped
thing what the instrument has done to it
so we're taking the absolute as we're
getting it through the instrument and
we're trying to remove the effects of
the instrument so that we get the
absolute by itself he says it becomes
exactly what it was before this effort
we didn't know what the hell this wasn't
a bit in the first place that's we're
trying to figure out through knowing
right so if we try to take out what the
instrument does we're actually removing
the part that tells us about what's over
here and we can say the same thing with
the medium he says by testing cognition
which we conceived of as a medium if we
get to know the law it's refraction
we're using a visual metaphor here
it's useless to subtract this from the
end result for it's not the refraction
of the Ray but the rain itself where my
truth reaches us and that is cognition
so for removing that all we would get as
a pure direction or a blank space we
wouldn't get something that we can
actually work with now there's a third
possibility that Hegel considers in
terms of instrument he says maybe the
instrument is less intrusive than we
think
maybe it's and he's got this metaphor
here that a lot of us probably can't
relate to - well maybe it's like you
know a line stay
catching a bird and bringing it close to
us now a Lyman stick is a sticky stick
right so imagine something like flypaper
only on a stick
and you see a bird down there and you're
like yeah I'm gonna catch that bird and
you touch it with the stick and now the
bird can't get away so you know think of
something like a butterfly net or live
trap or you know whatever whatever works
for you and you're bringing the thing to
you undamaged unaltered you know maybe
screwed up a little bit panicked but
whatever is gonna happen with the bird
or insect you're gonna do that now with
the absolute so the instrument is just
to like grab onto the absolute and bring
it in over here hiegel says this is a
rubes this is a trick he says the
absolute would laugh at her little ruse
if it were not with us in and for itself
all along and of its own volition that's
an interesting thing to say that means
that the absolutes without us realizing
it is already over here and here's
here's a little bit of a story you know
where we're going with this the absolute
is getting to know itself through us
through our processes of cognition
through what it is it were trying to
make sense of through how we're
improving it over time this process so
the instrument is not so innocent it's
not so undamaged it's not so unobtrusive
uninterested as we thought that it was
when we made it out to be but it's not
the end of the story
so Hinkle is going to finish up this
section by saying that none of these are
actually ways of thinking about this
that are actually going to work for us
so what are we what are we actually left
with here should we just stop doing
epistemology altogether and say well
let's just jump right into the absolute
well that's not going to work now that
we've brought up this worry we're going
to be inhabited by it for a while until
we can resolve this worry and that's
part of what the
the introduction is really grappling
with so this first section here it's not
encapsulating the entire introduction
but it is setting the stage for all the
other themes that are going to emerge in
this section
meanwhile if the fear of falling into
error sets up a mistrust of science
which in the absence of such scruples
gets out of the work itself and actually
cognizance um thing it is hard to see
why we should not turn around and
mistrust this very mistrust should we
not be concerned as to whether this fear
of error is not just the error itself
indeed this fear takes something a great
deal in fact for granted as truth
supporting its scruples and inferences
on what is itself in need of prior
scrutiny to see if it is true to be
specific it takes for granted certain
ideas about cognition as an instrument
and as a medium and assumes that there
is a difference between ourselves in
this cognition above all it presupposes
that the absolute stands on one side and
cognition on the other independent
separated from it and yet is something
real or in other words it presupposes
that cognition which sense it's excluded
from the absolute is surely outside of
the truth as well is nevertheless true
an assumption whereby what calls itself
fear of error reveals itself rather as
fear of the truth
one way to address the problem of
skepticism this worry that we can never
really know anything because what we
take to be knowledge isn't really so or
the processes by which we're coming to
know things are somehow distorting them
or falsifying them one way to deal with
that is to suggest that skepticism
itself needs to be skeptical of that
very skepticism now that's rather self
reflexive to say that but so let me you
know let me say that one more time
you can see that skepticism is
self-defeating by the way in which it
makes sense out of the very problem of
knowledge or put in other terms
skepticism which seems to be saying well
you're making assumptions and we don't
want to make assumptions is making a
whole bunch of assumptions itself and
this characterizes the movement of
modern epistemology catalyst is kind of
undoing in this this section so he says
the fear of falling into error sets up a
mistrust of science and now you've got
he doesn't he's not talking about this
here but you've got sort of a divided
consciousness you've got you know people
who are actually doing things science
actually cognizes something doesn't
necessarily have to be the absolute it
could just be the objects of the Natural
Sciences it could be you know psychology
looking at the human mind its makeup how
it works could be history
right but there's science there's some
sort of discipline and it's getting to
know things and those who are involved
with that are not worried so much about
falling into error although they may be
you know suspicious you know if you're
doing historical research you have to be
a bit credulous of certain documents on
certain claims but if they're actually
getting on with the work and they're
getting to know things in the process
are they knowing them perfectly perhaps
not so they sometimes make mistakes yes
that's that's true but they're not
paralyzed by this fear of error that
keeps them from action
doing anything so you know if you want
to think about this in non-scientific
terms but in relationship terms think
about you know convincing yourself that
somebody loves you or not so if you're
gonna wait to act for the you know
absolute certainty that this person
loves you before you enter into a
relationship with them and you know date
and get to know them and get married and
have a life together and all this sort
of stuff well you're never gonna do it
right because the very getting on with
it and getting to know that as part of
how you figure it out in the first place
and if you just worry about I got to be
a hundred percent certain about this
you'll never get the opportunity to be a
hundred percent certain and it works
that way with disciplinary knowledge
knowledge of the world as well so he
says we should perhaps distrust this
very mistrust why should we not be
concerned as to whether this fear of
error is not just the error itself it's
a mistake to be so obsessed with getting
it a hundred percent right with
attaining perfect certainty and only
then moving on or only sticking within
the realm of that which we can be
99.99999% sure about you know he's Hagel
is really being a pragmatist here in
many respects and I don't mean just a
pragmatist like William James I mean a
pragmatist like like Blaise Pascal and
Maurice well know as well so he says
indeed this fear takes something a great
deal in fact for granted as truth what
is it taking for granted its truth all
this part down here and this is what we
just looked at before I we've got
ourselves cognition as either an
instrument or a medium and the absolute
and we're supposed to like use this
instrument to grasp what's what's real
what's true over here and so we've got
you know reality
or truth and now the implication here is
that there is actually some sort of bar
between the instruments medium how we're
getting to know the reality of truth so
that this is actually in some respect
false there was another assumption being
made to which is that we are not that
cognition we are something different
than cognition when actually we are that
that is part of what we are so there's
these sort of artificial separations
that are being imposed by this point of
view and that's part of why it gets
itself into such a tizzy about this he
says it assumes there's a difference
between ourselves and this cognition and
in a presupposes the absolute stands on
one side cognition on the other
independent and separated from it and
yet is something real and it presupposes
the cognition which is surely outside of
the truth which is false is also at the
same time true because it is really
cognition it is really what it is but
then does this dividing line really hold
up we know something about that the
cognition he says it presupposes that
cognition which sense is excluded from
the absolute is outside of the truth is
nevertheless true an assumption whereby
what calls itself fear of error reveals
itself instead as fear of the truth
again I want to just spend just a moment
here to go a little bit beyond this and
shoot into some of the other sections
when he was talking about truth here
truth is something you can think of as
bleeding over outside of the absolute
this isn't the best way to put it
because the absence does encompass
everything we're already inside of the
absolute but we just don't realize it
but truth bleeds out of that and gets
into all these other things as well so
there's more truth that we have access
to then we know what to do with we're
not able to recognize the
be true and all of the interconnections
between the true and such so we take it
to be false and then we're worried about
it we get scared and then we don't do
anything we say I need to withdraw
instead and so long as we do this and we
keep to ourselves we're never going to
get to know the absolute